is whether I set the how are you I'm
doing great Dave how are you doing I am
better than I deserve welcome to
Nashville where do you live
st. Petersburg Florida fun well thanks
for coming up very cool are you here to
do a debt free scream yes sir all the
way to Nashville how much have you paid
off a little over two hundred and twenty
thousand Wow and how long did that take
um a little over four years good for you
making what kind of money I started at
1:30 and I'm up to 148 now good for you
what do you do for a living I'm a nurse
in Ephesus ah good field very good field
is that your house you paid oh no no
that was the nursing that's the student
loans I guess yeah I guess okay cool so
a lot of the 220 was student loans how
much about 170 I had private and the
Sallie me I had Terry loans and I had a
siphon that I had to repay back and you
got after it man so you graduate four
years ago no actually I graduated in oh
nine Oh what happened four years ago
decided to make you get on this I was at
work and believe it or not an orthopedic
surgeon dr. Eden was in there and I was
just kind of looking down it was around
Christmastime and he gave me your book
for Christmas oh my god and he had been
following the pan and he uses the plan
and once I read it I was hooked Wow very
cool so he's like I cleaned up my doc
mess you clean up your nurse mess yeah
very cool good so for years you read
that you read the Total Money Makeover
you get on fire and you say I'm getting
out of that yes sir
and then what happened what'd you do I
stopped using my debit card I cut up all
my credit cards
I really just stopped eating out I just
really cut back on everything and it was
hard because I had friends going to
Paris and going different places and and
when I first started out I was driving
my daughter old Civic it was like 2002
with over 200,000 miles and driving up
into the doctors lounge with that I just
did it yeah but you're making 100 a half
you don't have any payments now yes sir
so you paid a price yes sir cool very
cool
what made you believe you can do that
that it would work I think it really
helped doing the smallest doing the
putting them in order and doing this
pause and seeing that accomplishment
just seeing that you you know those
little accomplishments really helped me
it's kind of like your mind to think you
might be able to do it when you start
but when you actually pay off the rim
then your emotions start to believe and
when four or five of them get paid off
it's like your spirit kicks in and it
believes yes sir yeah yes that's very
cool
well congratulations very well done so
when someone hears you have paid off two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars one
hundred and seventy in student loans and
they say how did you do that what do you
tell them the key things are the three
things you must do the two things you
must do to get out of debt you have to
love yourself enough to do it and love
your family and your kids I'm a single
parent or two adult kids now and I think
about some of the mistakes I made
raising them and with money and
everything and I said to myself if I
were to started this in my 30s Wow it
just would have been awesome so just and
being mature enough to put aside the
automatic rewards for the future and the
budget the budget and living on cash
because when you see the cash or just
you you is it just works it works a lot
better you you feel it when you spending
guys you really do you do wow I'm so
proud of you thank you you got to feel
great
how long has it been since you've been
debt-free how many years ago when your
last debt free were you a kid when years
old never never in your adult life Wow
Wow and how old are you that's all right
it's good I love it
I'm 46 so 26 30 years something like
that since you've been in debt-free
you know now you're completely free and
you're making Bank yeah I'm so proud of
you thank you you're awesome you inspire
people by doing this thank you single
mom and
and you went back in onine so I'm seven
years so you're in your 30s when you go
back to get your nursing nest
yeah I was working in the ICU and I
thought I was doing okay I used to pick
up a lot of shifts I was driving a nice
car and all of this stuff and um it just
was nugget at me to go back to school
yeah well your incomes gonna go straight
up yeah I mean you're not done on the
increases right this is gonna get even
better and and now you're gonna know
what to do with it yeah I'm so proud of
you know who came with you my daughter
Cherise alright Cherise thanks for being
then the cheering squad here very cool
Cynthia from Saint Petersburg Florida
two hundred and twenty thousand dollars
paid off in four years making a hundred
and thirty now 148 thousand count it
down let's hear a debt free scream one
two three
I'm debt free
oh that's fun
well done well done well done man that's
it yet oh you single moms out there
listening if you don't think it can be
done that was for you is I mean she
raised those kids and and she's an you
know got her nursing degree she's in
there working the ICU she's working
those extra hours looks up since I can
raise my income by going back to school
goes back to school makes a dadgum
student loan mess but gets a great
income and then steps up and cleans it
up that lady right there is a hero man
she's a hero wow that's fun
yeah that's proof you can do it shut up
you can do it Cynthia did it that's
awesome man very cool hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind